le garde manger c'est le nom de ce
nouveau magasin de produits fermiers
ouvert il y à un mois à la ferme de
romainville situe à manille les amours
le but étant de diversifier les
activités de la ferme
je suis monument agriculteurs issus
d'une famille d'agriculteurs je suis la
cinquième génération à reprendre la
ferme et c'est important pour moi de
faire vivre des agriculteurs de
présenter des produits fermiers donc
c'est pour ça qu'on voulait que ce soit
du circuit court dans ce magasin on peut
retrouver de la viande du miel du vin
des yeux ou encore du chocolat on est
comblé je trouve il ya tous les produits
elle a pensé à tout on peut faire un
repas complet ou faisaient des amis il y
aura des fleurs je crois possible si
parfait tous les produits ne proviennent
pas forcément à proximité de la ferme
mais ils sont tous issus d'une activité
agricole
la boutique est un relais pour les
producteurs on ne cherche pas à négocier
les prix on dit aux producteurs vous
nous dites à quel prix on doit vendre
votre produit
nous on applique une marge ce qui est
logique et après on vendre à ce prix là
entre guillemets si ça marche pas ce
sera votre faute parce que vous avez été
un peu trop gourmand mais nous on
cherche pas du tout à faire de pression
sur les prix ou quoi que ce soit la
clientèle provient souvent des communes
aux alentours
pour elle c'est une aubaine puisqu'il
n'y avait pas de magasin comme celui là
oui ça manquait et puis surtout des
produits dont on connaît l'origine et
qui sont étiquetés pour se repérer
savoir quels produits achetés une fiche
producteur a été écrite par les gérants
c'est vraiment pour informer le client
de la provenance
et surtout quel type de production
puisque nous on n'aura pas forcément le
temps d'expliquer à tout le monde
voilà
le type de produits comment ces faits
d'où ça vient et surtout qui est
derrière ce produit là et ça permet
voilà d'avoir des informations rapides
sur le producteur la boutique est
ouverte du mardi au vendredi de 10h à
13h et de 16h à 19h et le samedi de 10
heures à 13 heures et de 15 heures à 18
heures